welcome to the vulcan how y'all doing
tonight
thanks for coming out
please do not talk during the show
there's no heckling the comedians
respect the comedy or you're gonna get
kicked out
your first comment is a touring
headliner and a regular on kill tony
ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage hans kim
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up
good to be here how you guys doing
[ __ ] yeah please no one slap me tonight
[Music]
i know this is joe rogan's crowd so
he'll probably choke me out instead or
give me a turning sidekick or feed me
elk but uh good to be here
my name is hans kim i'm happy to be here
in texas with all our freedoms seeing
your maskless faces
i love wearing my mask because i'm a
liberal and i love smelling my own fear
turns me on sexually
oh yeah daddy tell me what to do biden
stick that metal dick in me fouchy
i was actually at a walmart and i saw a
guy take off his mask to cough
i was like how does this guy [ __ ]
oh i'm about to come let me take my
condom off real quick
i almost got semen in my condom
that would have been gross
uh if you couldn't tell i
love the ladies i
[ __ ] a lot
i was uh talking this girl and she was
like did you know that my vagina can
make a baby so my vagina is a 3d printer
i was like actually as an autistic
person that's incorrect
your womb is a 3d printer your vagina is
a tray
it only prints one thing with lots of
errors
it takes nine months to print
and the whole time is printing is
complaining
needless to say i did not say any trays
that night
i i am very gender fluid i am
biologically male but my bullies
identified me as a [ __ ]
i love how millennials are such
narcissists that if they're not a seven
or above they'll just dye the hair pink
and change their gender
it's like why don't you just be a four
and learn how to play guitar
[Applause]
but don't get me wrong i think trans
people should be able to use whatever
bathroom they want to use
i just don't think suicidal people
should because they make a mess
holy [ __ ]
they don't always clean up after
themselves
i love uh i love being an asian man no
one wants to [ __ ] me it's pretty hard
everyone wants to [ __ ] asian women but
how do you think asian women are created
me [ __ ] okay
if you want an asian woman you got to go
through my dick
i'm a crucial part of the sexy process
please stop trying to skip me
if you have sex with me our children
will be very beautiful
half of them
the other half will be great engineers
and that's important too
i think white women are intimidated to
date asian men because we're better at
being women than they are
i'm completely hairless i weigh 120
pounds
i have no confidence in myself
i'm basically the perfect woman
asian women act like they're hotter than
asian men but we look exactly the same
[ __ ]
i could throw on a wig and be a seven
relax
why are you bragging that you can [ __ ]
white dudes we can all [ __ ] white dudes
they're the easiest people to [ __ ]
i know you're hot here in america but
just remember back home we're throwing
you away
we got home field advantage [ __ ]
stay humble ladies
this is the goal body in asia
we see an asian woman we're like gross
dick is slightly smaller
um but uh i love being asian or as i'm
known in texas i'm chinese
[Applause]
i'm from a province in china called
south korea
it's right next to japan province
i experienced a lot of racism i was
walking down the street and this guy
comes up to me and he's like tokyo
do so i was like dude just because i
look like this doesn't mean i speak your
[ __ ] language
and the post office is right there
a lot of my asian friends make fun of me
because i like to eat at panda express
they're like hans isn't panda express
just a shitty americanized version of
something authentically
asian i was like yeah but so am i
my favorite movie is rush hour 3.
love being asian because i can walk into
starbucks and tell them that my name is
ching chong bing bong the third
and they have to write it down on the
cup
what are they gonna say
hey they saw your name
excuse me skyler
i come from a long line of bing bongs
what are you a ding-dong
i love a tear in texas i love rednecks
because rednecks can survive in any
wilderness situation that you put them
in
except a situation where everyone has
equal rights
kind of [ __ ] them up
you can live in a swamp with an
alligator why can't you live in a
cul-de-sac with a minority
have you tried smiling
i think it's funny that tanner is a
white person's name i mean tanner then
what
should be like hey this is my mexican
friend tanner
that's my black friend tanist
just a suffix joke i am uh
i am not a racist of course i'm a
minority how could i be impossible
i don't even see race
i mean i barely see much of anything but
i definitely don't see race
i only smell it
especially in those ubers am i right
crack a window muhammad
[Applause]
i'm not a racist i uh
i was actually on an airplane and i saw
a dude reading a book in arabic which
kind of freaked me out but then i saw
him fold the corner of the page and put
the book away and i was like oh thank
god he's got future plans
not a racist but uh
i did think that la fitness was a
mexican gym because i thought it was
pronounced la fitness
the punching bags are just pinatas
the treadmills have lawnmower handles
i i think the confederate flag is kind
of funny i feel like the confederate
flag would be like if a man went to his
wife and he was like hey honey remember
that time i went into that huge argument
and i try to divorce you
yeah i'm pretty proud of that time
kind of represents who i am as a person
so i got our divorce papers tattooed on
my chest
[Music]
but i'm uh doing pretty good my sister
just got back from a mission trip if you
don't know what that is that's where
americans go to third world countries to
get new profile pictures
she was like did you know that your
toilet water is cleaner than the
drinking water in africa
i was like these are the pipes that we
have what do you want me to do about it
if i see an african walking down the
street i'll let them drink from my
toilet
just flush afterwards i don't want to
get aids
all right that's my tom are you guys
ready for a great [ __ ] show
this next comedian has performed in
clubs all over texas give it up for the
baddest [ __ ] in austin texas liz split
[Applause]